and now for something completely
different
not that different okay that's even
better
i don't think maybe not
so um
our next talk i'm really really happy
that
robert treber could come and give a talk
here
in spite of having teaching
at an inconvenient time at mcgill
and robert has done a lot of
very very interesting work boson proof
complexity and
computational complexity and
communication complexity
and i don't even know
in particular some of the best results
on lifting theorems and
use of those communication complexity
techniques in
proof complexity and beyond um
robert's work and hopefully you will
tell us
um more about this beautiful set of
tools that you helped develop over the
last few years
cool uh all right thanks thanks uh
thanks for the organizers for inviting
me i'm
excited to give this talk uh i'm i only
have a short amount of time so i have to
give the same i unfortunately have to
give the same uh
preamble that joanna did i can't go too
into details
with uh with things but um so today we
today is just going to be kind of a
gentle introduction for people who
for a general introduction into lived
into these lifting theorems for people
who
uh may not be too familiar with the
techniques and
i'm sure that suzanna will talk a little
bit more about these things too
afterwards
um okay cool so
um so
the main message of this talk is that
one of the most powerful tools that we
have in in proof complexity is
composition
and so what do i mean by by composition
here
well um if we let f throughout we're
just going to let
uh capital f be in some unsatisfiable
cnf formula
usually we think of these clauses as
being bounded width but that's not
especially important
um and if we think of associated with
with f say we could have this some sort
of function g which we'll refer to as a
gadget function just think of it as some
arbitrary boolean function if you want
something concrete for now
you can think of say the two-bit xor but
in general you could pick something more
you could pick something else then we
can define the
a composed formula that you get from
composing together f and g
so by this i just mean take all the
variables of f
and plug in copies of this gadget g on
fresh
comp like conjure up new very new copies
of variables
for each of these zi's right here okay
and then what we'll do is we'll we'll
plug
g in on these new variables for each of
these z's
and then we'll rewrite this as a c and
formula so it'll still be unsatisfiable
after we do this composition
okay so now the
kind of one of the remark like the the
message of these of these uh
of these lifting theorems that i'm going
to be talking about today
is basically the following if we have
two proof systems p and q you could even
pick p equal to q if you like
can we somehow relate the best p
refutations of f to the best q
refutations
of the composed function of the composed
formula
f and g okay
and the surprising answer is that this
is a very general question
and it's so general that it it might
like be approaching vagueness
but the surprising answer to this
question is that sometimes you can
actually really say yes
uh and so these general family of
results and proof complexity are
typically called lifting theorems
and so where does this name lifting
theorem come from well it just comes
from the fact that
if you think of p as being like a simple
proof system
and you think of q as being some sort of
complicated proof system
then this such a result allows you to
like lift
analyses from p to q as long as you're
happy with the
with the results in q being for these
composed formulas
and the the rough intuition for these
things
is that if this gadget g is somehow
hard to compute in the stronger proof
system q
then the best thing that q can do is
just simulate p proofs
for f while paying some local overhead
every time it needs to use the gadget g
and this this local overhead can really
cause different complexity parameters to
blow up
over the over the courses of the proofs
and kind of the remarkable thing
is that if we vary p and q and g
then we can get quite strong control
over a big family of proof complexity
parameters
okay so that's this is kind of the
general
uh uh blow up so there are the the
general idea so
today i'm going to give everybody sort
of a general introduction i'm going to
focus on
just two proof systems resolution and
cutting planes but there's also results
known for other proof systems
so let's just start off with some
concrete examples so
uh we can start we can choose the inner
gadget g to be
xor to start off so let's let f just be
some unsatisfiable cnf formula let's let
xor be the usual two-bit xor okay
and then how do we define this this
composed formula just really explicitly
so that we have something concrete to
work from
well we just kind of do it in the most
natural way so what we're going to do is
we're going to encode
x each xor as a tiny c and f itself
so every time i have a variable zi i'll
replace it with a tiny
cnf formula that encodes x i parity y i
and if i have the negation of zi well
then i can replace it with a cnf formula
which replaces the negation or like
you know this is equivalently the
equality between two between
x i and y i and then after we do this
substitution into the cnn formula f
we'll just use the distributive rule to
rewrite the c and if to rewrite
the new substituted formula into c and f
itself and
this is pretty pretty obvious but
because we haven't changed anything
about the semantics of f the resulting
formula after doing a substitution is
still going to be unsatisfiable
so for an example you know if this is
our simple little
see our simple little cnf formula here
well
for z1 we would substitute in the the
xor of x1 and y1 for z2 we would
substitute in the negation
of the xor of x2 and y2 which we also
encode as c and f
and then after we do this substitution
we end up getting something that looks
like this
so up here we have the substitution for
z1 and then down here we have the
substitution for this clause
and then by distributing over this this
red or here we would obtain a cnf
formula okay
and when you do this in general it's not
too hard to convince yourself that if
the formula you started with had
w claw had width w and m clauses
then after doing this composition well
the new formula is going to have width
at most 2w
because every variable gets replaced
with two but
the number of clauses is going to blow
up exponentially in the width and that
just comes from this distributive law
right here so
i have two clauses here if i with w when
i do the just like the distribution over
all of them
i'm gonna end up getting an exponential
blow up so in general when we compose
with xor
it's only really sensible if you start
with a bounded width formula
so even though xor is a simple gadget
in some sense there's many simple proof
systems that people are interested
in for which which can't count mod 2
right
and resolution is kind of the canonical
example of this
so composing with xor already gives very
simple family of lifting results
so kind of the canonical one that i
think of is the following which is just
an easy corollary of a padlock and
polygazo
if i take any unsatisfiable cnf formula
at all
then this the minimal size of a
tree-like
resolution refutation of f composed with
xor is at least
two to the depth of the resolution uh
complexity or the depth complexity and
resolution of refuting f
and this kind of encapsulates a lot of
the things that we see in these lifting
theorems
so we have we have uh two different
parameters
depth and size in two different proof
systems in this case they're they're
closely related but they're different
proof systems
right and the complexity parameter of
the first guy
in in in one proof system gets lifted to
a different complexity parameter of the
composed function in the second proof
system
and uh later if we have i mean okay well
i mean resolution depth in this case
like this is a win
for us because resolution depth is very
very easy to lower bound it's just the
same as lower bounding like decision
tree depth
which we know how to lower bound so if
you want to prove size lower bounds for
tree-like resolution well then this
gives you a totally mechanical method
with which to do it
right and later we'll see a proof of
this if
if we have time because i think it's
simple and maybe
many people have already seen it but i
think it does give it does illustrate a
lot of the examples
yeah absolutely resolution depth is
equal to tree like resolution depth yeah
there's no difference here
so um moving away just from xor it's not
like all the lifting theorems that we
that we prove are uh using the xor
gadget
a very popular gadget that people like
to consider is the so-called
indexing function or the also known as
the addressing function
and the indexing function is pretty
simple so all it says is that
okay if i have uh if
if we think of the inputs as being
partitioned into two groups
and we think of y as being a big string
and x as being a pointer into that
string and then we just
output the bit that's pointed to by by x
and y um robert there was a
question by kanye hunter i don't know if
you could see the chat
yeah it is i see it it is resolution
depth was equal to tree like resolution
depth and yeah absolutely it is
yeah but you know that's just because
you can you can you can do the recursive
expansion but you know the
the message of what i said is still true
robert a quick question yep so you
mentioned when you um
the when you replace the variable z with
the
xor gadgets there is a blow up in the
size of the formula in terms of w right
yep but what if i
performed a kind of a satan encoding so
that the blow up
is not there a polymer there's only a
polynomial blow up yeah
that's going to trade off into the
number of variables
oh i see yeah that's true you you could
do that but then the trade-off would
just go into the number of variables of
the formula
so any lower bound that you proved would
still be weaker in a corresponding way
right you haven't somehow hidden the
size right the size is still there it's
just encoded a different parameter
right um
any other questions
okay so um
back to this uh back to this indexing
function here so um
we think of in this indexing function we
think of like y
as being a big long string and then we
think of x as just being a pointer into
it
so all we do is we just take x we we
eval
we consider it as a binary pointer we
point into y and then we output whatever
the bit that that's pointed at by x here
and in some sense the reason why the
index gadget is nice and why we consider
it all the time
is because um for
for many proof systems which you can
kind of think of as being query based
like they kind of you can think of
tree-like resolution for example you can
think of it as dpl where we sort of
query variables from the top down and we
explore this proof tree in the
in a sort of top-down way and this is
also very you know useful in tuition for
sat solvers
and in some sense this indexing function
is is a very
difficult function for query algorithms
to evaluate right
the only way that we can really evaluate
the indexing function by these top-down
query algorithms
is just by you can't do anything better
really than just evaluating all of x
and then evaluating the corresponding
bit of y
um and
a problem that comes when we wanted to
find the the composed formula with the
indexing function here so before with
xor we were just sort of directly
blasting xor down into a c and f and
substituting it in and then distributing
well with indexing you're really going
to get a giant you you really
run into the possibility of getting a
very big blow up
when you do this right so usually when
we encode
the composed formula with with index
what we do is we do a more
a more sort of general encoding which
still turns out to be okay for all the
proofs
so um i'll just give a sketch of this
encoding just so just so everybody gets
an idea of what
these a more general idea of what these
composed formulas can look like
so again if f is on these n variables z1
through zn
then this composed formula is going to
look like this so we'll introduce
some some xi variables and some yi
variables just like we did before
so the x i's are like the pointer inputs
to the indexing and
to the copies of the index function and
the y eyes are the are the
like the the the tables like the truth
tables that that x i is pointing into
and the key thing here is that we've
really encoded these pointers in unary
so for every single j in l
um we're going to have a we're going to
have a pointer variable that corresponds
to that
that being the that being the evaluation
of the whole pointer gap
the whole pointer input so then now we
can just sort of
uh write down what this composed form is
going to look like a bit more abstractly
so first we're going to say okay well
every single
like every single input has to have some
pointer the pointer has to point
somewhere
for every single for every single input
index
so we add these extra clauses that just
say this
and then for every clause in my original
formula of f
what i'm going to do is is if i have zi
in the clause
i'll substitute it with something that
says you know if the pointer from i
to j is true then output y i j this is
just saying you know if i'm pointing at
j then i should output then that
variable should really be y i j
and if not zi is in the clause well then
if i point
to j then i should really be outputting
the negation
of that bit and then we just perform
this substitution for
every variable that appears in the
clause and all possible choices of j
that we can choose to substitute in
so this i mean this still gives you
quite a blow up but it wouldn't be as
bad if you just
directly blasted it down to cnf and then
folded it out
at the end of the day if your start
formula you're starting formula head
with w
and and m clauses then this composed
formula is going to have something like
you know with 2w or l if these if these
pointer clauses are the biggest one
and the blow up turns into something
like l to the w and that comes from
this clause substitution where we have
to plug in these x i's for every single
for every single entry there um okay
cool
so what can you do with this indexing
function well the indexing function is
intuitively much harder to evaluate than
the xor function is
and as a result we can prove stronger
lifting theorems for it so
a really nice example of this which
this follows the earlier template where
the the the two proof systems p and q
are the same
if we let w of f be the maximum width
of any clause that occurs in f and we
let w sub res of f be the minimum
width of any resolution refutation of f
this is a pretty familiar parameter
which controls size complexity
and resolution well then after composing
with this index function
resolution size turns into pretty much
exactly n to the resolution width okay
so here we're here this is a kind of
lifting theorem
in the sense that you know now the proof
systems are the same but the but we've
measured one complexity parameter of f
the width and we've converted it into a
size lower bound on
f composed with the indexing function
here and this is it's helpful it's kind
of nice to contrast this with the other
known results that connect with to size
lower bounds and
such as the you know the famous size
width translation due to benzasson
victorson
um now what's surprising about this is
that the indexing gadget is not only
hard for resolution once you compose
with index
width doesn't lift to resolution size it
goes all the way to cutting plane size
so here's a if people have seen the the
the boot camp talk so they'll recognize
it so robert can you go back one slide
yeah so for this result um
the original formula that you started
off with before you plugged in your
gadget into it
yep what class of formulas is that is
there randomly generated formula or is
it a specific class of formulas or
is this any formula at all for any
single formula
any formula okay yeah awesome yes so
it's very powerful in that sense you
have no
constraints a priori on f of course
one comment is that if like the
resolution width equals the width of f
in this case well then the size of the
original formula is going to have size
you know
end of the w already so this is kind of
not saying anything
but um i mean it's still tight but you
know it doesn't give you it doesn't it
gives you the op
like the tight lower bound but this
gives you a much stronger lower bound on
the resolution width of f
thanks
uh any other questions
okay cool
so um as i was just saying resolution
width it already turns out when you
compose with this index gadget it
already lifts
all the way to cutting plane size so
what's the cutting plane's proof system
well
um it's maybe it'll be familiar if
you've seen the uh if you've seen the
the uh the the boot camp talks but the
cutting planes produced still in
the cutting planes proves the lines are
integer linear inequalities
and then we deduce new linear
inequalities from them kind of in
in the following way so if i have two
inequalities then i can
deduce their their any non-negative
linear combination of them
um i mean this is sound over real
assignments this doesn't really do
anything for us for
you know for our purposes of considering
like proper proof systems like zero one
proof systems
and then we also have this division rule
which says you know if i have
some some inequality ax and b and i have
some integer which divides all the
entries of a
then i can divide by a on the on the
left side and then
divide by or divide by d on the on the
left hand side and then divide by d on
the right hand side while rounding up
and the reason for this is we're
considering integer solutions for these
x variables
so since a and b are integers since
everything here is integers
if i divide by d on the right hand side
then this is already gonna then
then i can happily take the ceiling just
because i'm not dealing with real
solutions
and the cutting plains proof system is
one of the is a really nice proof system
it has lots of relations to optimization
and it's also been very sort of
influential proof complexity is one of
these
proof systems which is kind of on the
border for which we i would i would say
we really understand
and one of the nice theorems that falls
out of the
the previous paper that i mentioned that
proved the thing for resolution as well
is that lifting resolution with after
composing with
with index already goes all the way to
cutting plane size
so for any cnf formula at all if i
as long as i choose my index and gadget
to be sufficiently large something like
polynomial and
n like the number of underlying
variables then the cutting plane
size of f composed with the indexing
gadget is already into the resolution
width
of f so this is a this is a real proper
lifting theorem it kind of relates two
different complexity parameters of two
different proof systems on different
formulas okay
and i mean this is just the tip of the
iceberg that there's been a
massive there's been an explosion of
these uh
of these uh lifting results here i've
just listed some of them relating
resolution and resolution in cutting
planes
but you can see here that um you know i
can relate things like resolution depth
to tree like size
resolution depth to cutting planes depth
um
resolution width to size and the gadgets
in general they're not even restricted
to just being xor or the index gadget
so um a very nice paper recently showed
that resolution depth lifts to tree like
size
even if you plug in any gadget which has
a very generic
property which we call low discrepancy i
don't want to get into the definition of
it but let's just say it's like a very
very nice property that many gadgets
that you might consider like
inner product or lots of other functions
satisfy this
um and then we have i listed here just
for the sake to show that you know we
can get
lifting theorems outside of just this
resolution and cutting planes
and that's if i start with like the null
stellin sats degree like an algebraic
proof system
we can compose with any gadget that has
high enough rank
and get a proper lifting theorem all the
way up to cutting planes
modulo with bounded coefficients okay
so um this is really kind of a powerful
tool and
and the applications are kind of growing
by the day i would say
um okay and now
it's not to say that these lifting
theorems are just used to connect
just used to prove something like size
lower bounds they can also be used to
prove uh trade-offs between
lots of standard proof complexity
parameters so just for a sample i mean i
don't have time to go into all the
results here but just for a sample of
the kind of results you can prove
here's a canonical example for cutting
planes if i start with any unsatisfiable
formula
and i compose with um and i compose with
the index gadget
well then you can get a trade-off result
between the
line space in cutting planes and the
size of cutting planes in terms of the
resolution depth of refuting f
so i start with f um i have this
uh i take the resolution the resolution
depth of f times this log n this log n
just comes up
from evaluating the gadget and we can
actually prove a trade-off result this
says that
neither space and log size can't both be
simultaneously small
okay and i mean even by taking this
result and
and modifying it a little bit there's
there's other results
by the same set of authors even which
shows how to get a three-way trade-off
in cutting planes so not only between
space and size but you can also include
say
space log of size and the maximum size
of any coefficient in a cutting plane's
proof so
all three of these can't be
simultaneously small
for example
um okay
so um now after you see all these uh all
these
all these results you might be wondering
like is there any rhyme or reason to
them
at all like where is it coming from why
is width correspond to size why does
depth correspond to size you know why do
these gadgets
what's the sort of underlying structure
of everything here
and the answer is that it all builds on
deep connections between
three areas of complexity so circuit
complexity communication complexity and
proof complexity
okay and in fact when i was showing
these strong
proof systems earlier the the correct
i mean the strongest possible way to
state the results
is is to define these strong proof
systems in terms of communication
protocols
i don't really have time to go into the
details of this but this is just to
let people know that there's some sort
of systematic theory actually underlying
all of this
um so in the model of two-party
communication complexity in case you
haven't seen it
um we have two players alice and bob
they want to
compute some function together but the
the input is bipartite so alice gets
one half of the input bob gets the other
half of the input
and then they want to output the
function and they're the only limitation
is that they have to communicate bits
with each other across this
communication channel
and so their goal is to evaluate the
function while minimizing the amount of
bits communicated
and the kind of the message is that
these protocols in all the examples that
i gave before there is
sort of a a notion of communication
protocol that actually the strong proof
system
corresponds to in this big table uh and
these protocols can simulate the proof
systems basically so
uh the the relationship here is between
refuting an unsatisfiable formula and
solving the so-called like
unsatisfiable clause search problem so
given an assignment you know find
fi given an assignment to my
unsatisfiable cnf
find a falsified clause okay
so these protocols you know they can
simulate these earlier proof systems and
the lifting theorems actually lift these
proof complexity parameters to these two
communication protocol parameters
and it turns out that these
communication protocols when you define
them this way
are equivalent to standard boolean
circuit models so this
basically generalizes this classical
customer vigorously connection from the
80s that connects communication
complexity with
uh with circuit complexity if you're not
familiar with this don't don't worry
about it this is just sort of a
just sort of an invitation in case
you're in case you're curious
um and i'll finally remark that that
we've been
we worked a little bit we've we've
worked on developing a more general
theory
that tries to capture as many of these
lifting relationships as possible
using subclasses of tfnp so people who
saw christos talk
last week sort of saw this proof
complexity
he sort of mentioned you know the proof
complexity has a
many proof complexity or many proof
systems sorry
have natural interpretations as sort of
query versions of
of these tfnp subclasses well it turns
out that
uh you can also consider like
communication complexity versions
of these tfnp classes and what these
lifting theorems basically do
is they relate the query complexity
version
with the communication complexity
version and that is the very general
picture but this isn't a complete
picture we've just managed to capture
many of the things many of the many of
the relationships that appear
and yeah there's still lots of
interesting work to be done in this
direction
um so uh also let me comment that
there's been
recently i mean another thing you might
point out is that why am i
forcing myself to you know evaluate
independent
like put in independent new variables
when i do this substitution
and there's been some recent work that's
even been considering these kind of
things and you can still get interesting
results in this case
so uh so in the standard lifting we have
our formula
f and we have it's on some variables and
then we substitute in this g
and all of these g's are defined on
totally independent input variables
and so you can naturally imagine coming
up with some sort of
generalized lifting where we allow
overlapping on the input variables
so here i've i've you know i have the
same number of x variables as i do z's
but in fact in the more in the more
recent theorems you can even contract
the number of variables here down even
smaller
and if you wire these edges up
say like an expander or something like
that then it turns out that you can
sometimes preserve the hardness of
evaluating the composed function of f
um and the the the classic separation if
you're familiar with it between regular
resolution and resolution is basically
of this type
we kind of compose with an index gadget
but we just
use the same domain for all the for all
the possible copies of the index gadget
um but recently it's been this idea has
been sort of improved to give
very very strong trade-offs between
things like uh tree-like resolution size
and resolution width
by raspberrov he showed that if i have a
if i have a small width tree like
refutation
then if i go even a little bit below
what the
what the maximal width is like if i if i
have it
not the maximum width if i go even a
little bit below um what a width for a
small tree like resolution refutation is
i can blow up the size of the proof even
doubly exponentially
um and there's also this nice recent
work by bear colts and nordstrom showing
similar trade-offs on these overlapping
gadgets between resolution with
resolution space so um
how am i doing for time
oh well if you want to take a few more
minutes
that's okay if it's fuel yeah um
okay i'll just say a few words about
this and then i'll finish then
so let me just say a few words about
this sort of simple lifting theorem just
to finish off just to give people sort
of a flavor of how these things
of how these things work um so
the idea here you know we okay so here's
the simple form simple theorem we're
going to use we take
start off with any unsatisfiable formula
you like um
and what we'll argue is that this that
the tree-like resolution
size of f composed with xor is at least
two to the resolution depth of f
so now uh we're probably everyone here
is probably familiar with
with tree-like resolution so we have
something that we have a a
resolution refutation it looks like this
we have we can resolve on individual
variables
and of course we have this sort of
top-down
equivalent way of viewing this formula
in terms of dpl
so i can i basically the idea is that if
i replace each of these resolution steps
with querying a variable from the top
down well then i can explore down
until i hit falsified clauses by my path
and then uh you know the the
the overall size of the search strategy
and the depth of the search strategy
corresponds directly to the
depth and the size of the corresponding
tree like resolution proof
so okay so how do we prove lower bounds
on this depth
on on resolution depth well the idea is
to use these uh prover adversary games
which are very closely related to the
spoiler duplicator games that
that joanna mentioned last time
and here what it is well we have this
game it alternates between approver and
an adversary and this is just modeling
uh you know approver trying to generate
a dpl tree
and an adversary forcing them to play as
long as possible
right so the prover selects a variable x
i to query and then the adversary
selects some bit
that forces the the prover to go on for
as long as possible
now the prover's goal is to find a false
clause in f and the adversary's goal is
to delay the
for as long as you can so say if we took
this example maybe the approver queried
the variables according to
this strategy here and the adversary
gets to choose
wants to force the prover to take a long
path well if the approver starts by
querying x3
the adversary can force him to set it to
zero then the proof of queries x1 and
then he forces it to one and then so on
right
now we've got a a three round protocol
a three round game here and that's just
because the depth of the corresponding
proof here is three
and there's a general connection that
sort of characterizes resolution depth
in this way
sorry about that here we go so in
general if you have an adversary
strategy that forces all approvers to
take
uh d rounds then the depth the
resolution depth is at least d
and you can even characterize this in
terms of upper bounds as well by
approver strategies
so the nice thing about tree like
resolution is that there's also a nice
way to use prover adversary games to
lower bound tree-like size
so i mean here we have exactly the same
game as before
but now the adversary instead of always
choosing bits
he can let the prover choose and
whenever he lets the prover choose he
scores a point
uh and this kind of when the approver
chooses he's always going to go to the
smaller side of the proof without loss
of generality
and so by mimicking the argument i gave
a second ago what you end up showing is
that
whenever there's an adversary that
scores d points against the prover
well then the the tree-like resolution
size of f
is something like two to the d okay uh
and in general the idea for converting
resolution depth to tree like resolution
size
is is pretty simple if i start with a
with a
depth adversary over here on f
what i'll do is i'll just convert his
strategy
into a strategy for the adversary on the
size game for f compose with xor
and i won't go any more of the details
because i'm already running a little bit
over time but the intuition should
somehow be clear right
whenever the approver queries one of the
bits in the two pairs of the xor
the adversary lets the lets them query
it however they like
um on the other hand if they if the
adversary queries say
if the approver queries the second bit
in a fixed xor then the adversary then
then the adversary just looks at the
depth adversary and sets it so that
everything is consistent
and since the depth game adversary can
push the game for
for d rounds the size game adversary can
score at least d
points so let me just skip over
the proof here because i ran a little
bit long but
let me just say here that the other
lifting theorems in general
use the same high level strategy so
usually instead we use approver strategy
so we'll say if i have a proof
in the in the lifted space then i can
convert this back into an efficient
proof
in the in the unlifted space so it
doesn't always lift adversaries to
adversary sometimes it lifts proofs to
proofs in the contrapositive direction
um okay cool so in conclusion what i
talked about today is just kind of the
tip of the iceberg and these lifting
theorems
and it's a relatively simple but also
very powerful tool to generate hard
formulas and also get quite strong
control over various proof complexity
parameters
and i've just talked about resolution in
cutting planes because there's lots of
nice
results proved there but there's lots of
other theorems proof for algebraic proof
systems and semi-algebraic proof systems
um really there's and of course also
there's the whole realm of
corresponding theorems and communication
complexity and circuit complexity
um and yeah so the main message i guess
is uh you know if you're
interested in sort of getting some nice
control over different parameters this
is a really powerful tool to have a look
into
uh and yeah thanks everybody for
listening so if anybody has any
questions go ahead
thank you so much robert questions
comments
i'll post it in a chat or just unmute
and ask
i have a question yes so you mentioned
that this lifting is something used in
communication complexity
uh i was wondering so this is in the
model of uh two
players so would it also work in the i
mean
is there work of using lifting in the
number in the forehead model
yes yeah absolutely um so in particular
for
uh for lava shriver proofs you can
there's been lifting theorems
uh like like a few lifting theorems sort
of relating the communication complexity
in number and forehead
to proving various size basically space
length trade-offs
just like we saw for cutting planes for
a low bosch driver
i can give you some some references if
you'd like but does it reach
size or it has to be a trade-off has to
be bounded space
um there's no it doesn't go all the way
up to size and the reason is because
when you're doing tree like um like
the number on forehead communication
protocols are sort of inherently
tree-like
and the the the low-lash driver proofs
are
if you think of them as being dag-like
in general well then something kind of
has to give in this tree like to
stag like keep forgetting i keep
forgetting that
the communication complexity yeah
exactly
so there is dag like communication
complexity and you could conceivably
define
dag-like number on forehead complexity
but i don't know if anybody's ever
thought about that to be honest
yeah it's a very nice question
more questions comments
well uh robert would you be open to
having like a tutorial on this at some
point
in the workshop yeah sure so
so yeah we'll get back to them but it
depends on when but yeah of course
yeah yeah chat later but yeah thank you
let me just comment if i may
no you mean yes
yeah yes i i just want to say that
there is no no parity gadget in our
paper with
uh redress so so we just had this again
but not
uh not this uh relation
right yeah i was uh just saying it as a
uh
i was yeah i i was trying to be careful
and saying it's an easy corollary
i didn't mean to attribute it to you
thanks thanks pablo
[Music]
okay more questions comments
[Music]
if not then thank you very very much
robert
and maybe let's take like two minutes to
refill our coffee cup
or whatever you're drinking wherever you
are
and uh we'll start in two minutes with
sudana stock